he was remarkable I mean what I've been
listening to these tributes all day and
I've got to say that some of the things
that people have been saying has been
very kind but possibly not what he would
like to have heard the truth is that he
was actually a very private individual a
very very quiet man he actually had a
very close circle of friends who he kept
to and kept within his loop if you like
and he was a go garius outgoing person
that was his personality but there was
this other site room that was an
incredibly personal quiet man he
sometimes had his demons we all know
about those I saw them
probably more than anybody else in
Parliament at the time but actually he
was what you got the Kennedy the you saw
on television the Kennedy they went to
the United Nations with the Kennedy that
you saw around the studios of why I Got
News for you that was the same cut
Charles Kennedy that would sit back late
at night in your house in Hereford or in
Fort William and he was real and he
didn't put on the face he didn't put on
a disguise
unlike sadly most politicians these days
what you saw with Charles Kennedy is
what you got do you think that entering
the world of politics at the tender age
of 23 was actually a struggle for him
although it was his passion in life and
what drove him ultimately he was complex
and he wanted to have a private life he
wasn't really afforded that he had to
speak very publicly about his demons his
problems with drink as we know do you
think that he actually struggled with
the kind of abrasive side of politics
yes I I think you're up see right I mean
I think look I was an MP for 13 years
entering the house and I was 35 when I
got there that was early enough to get
there when you're 23 with really no life
experience at all and then to do the job
and then to do it so well as he did it
so quickly
that put him into the top league
immediately and I've never understood
this desire to have a younger and
younger MPs and all of this stuff you
need people who can actually deal with
crisis and deal with life and Charles I
think did come to those two young he
admitted that occasioning very privately
but normally he just got on with it but
he could cope with that or so many
people thought it was actually only
later on in his career as leader that
people began to realize that there was
this problem there was this demon and I
do think I think you're right I think
part of that demon was caused by the
fact that he went to Westminster too
young and he didn't have that grounding
in life that I think you really need to
be a good constituency MP and a good
politician he didn't have that